the governor of Missouri granted a
last-minute stay of execution after DNA
testing raised new doubts about the
guilt of a death row inmate Marcellus
Williams was scheduled to be put to
death last night for the 1998 murder of
Felicia Gale tonita copal shows us the
impact of a recent review of evidence
Tony good morning good morning Marceau's
Williams attorneys say the new DNA
evidence found on the murder weapon
matched an unknown person and not their
client Governor on Greitens plans to
appoint a five-member board to recommend
whether Williams should be executed or
now granted clemency
Marcellus Williams knows his father's
exoneration is still a long shot
Williams was convicted of stabbing a
former newspaper reporter Felicia Gale
43 times with a butcher knife inside her
home back in 1998 it's sad because this
woman she was murdered
and her killer still walking the streets
in 2015 Missouri Supreme Court delayed
Williams execution to allow for DNA
testing that was not available during
trial
Larry comp is one of Williams attorneys
we're looking at an execution a couple
hours from now and the governor
interceded and now we'd get our day in
court and talk about what these results
mean the governor's executive order
states the inquiry board has the power
to gather information whether or not
admissible in a court of law
to make their recommendation the
Innocence Project took notice after an
online petition calling for a stop to
his execution received more than 250,000
signatures Barry Scheck is one of its
co-founders and if you're going to
execute somebody you ought to have a
really good fact-finding process here we
have an individual that DNA testing is
showing could well be innocent it's it's
very troubling
Missouri's Attorney General has defended
the prosecution of Williams and said in
a statement we remain confident in the
judgment of the jury and the many courts
that have carefully reviewed mr.
Williams case over 16 years oh my father
situation shows people that we didn't
get people
and treat everybody equally two
witnesses reportedly claimed Williams
confessed to the burglary and the
killing but defense attorneys say those
witnesses are unreliable and were
motivated by a ten thousand dollar
reward
Gail all right thank you very much Tony